des voyages plus organisé auprès des
professionnels pour être accompagnés
jusqu'au bout dans cette agence à
noisy-le-roi les envies vont vers le
soleil les caraïbes le mexique ou encore
la réunion beaucoup de demandes de devis
les gens vraiment envie de partir au
niveau concrétisation on est loin encore
de ce qu'on pouvait faire avant la
pandémie mais c'est en bonne voie les
gens veulent partir les gens en vie on
voit qu'ils ont envie de se faire
plaisir ils ont envie de vraiment tout
lâcher de se laisser porter par l'
agence ils nous demandent vraiment
d'organiser tout du début à la fin de
nouveaux clients des familles moins
regardantes sur le budget un plaisir
pouvant aller jusqu'à 6000 euros par
personne vous appeler pour vous demander
si la croisière sur le nil vous
intéressez toujours dans cette agence
oscille envie de soleil est en tête des
réservations les durées de séjour n'ont
pas évolué les clients partent toujours
au minimum 8 jours et 7 nuits le long
courrier ils ont encore un petit peu de
mal s'est il se projette pas sur le long
courrier mais sur le moyen courrier oui
et c'est plus des destinations où nous
demandent des devis pour 2023 2024
placez vraiment années elle a six mois
des vacances d'été les prévisions des
voyagistes sont au beau fixe les raisons
les frontières qui rouvrent peu à peu